I worked out in cold gym today this is
interesting it's an interesting place to
throw back it smells like farts and
protein powder smells like farts and
redline energy drinks it's it's yeah
it's um it is got all those old-school
bodybuilders they're still there man yep
I saw its Lewis Cormier it was Chloe
remember Chris Cormier he's a trainer
there yep he's training there yep he's
still huge and and but old-school body
builder old-school 70s 80s 80s no 90s
unless you lose the mr eelan
yeah he's like la yeah like the late 90s
to say really oh yeah
yeah well use Chris Corey Olympia that's
correct
he's always around
he's still there yep Hey yep Google I'll
say that a lot of the women some of
those women there don't do depressing
dude you'll remember I grew up there
right my uncle passed was one of those
guys Oh a little depressed you've been
going there because I was going there 27
years ago 25 years ago 25 years for me
and you too but I was there when I was
older and I came back for the first time
today and I saw see people's seal their
faces just 25 years older it was crazy
in the same workout gear yeah that's
true and you know somewhere like the
spandex yeah it's because it's what when
they fell they hood when they were at
their peers when they wore it and now
they're yeah yeah now that's he's
natural right look at that back you'll
catch Arnold in there I talked to her
all about that works out there yeah one
good log there yep I won't say when
because yeah let's seen Arnold in there
I've seen I mean everyone goes it's like
uh you know it's a historic landmark do
that but don't do that is that is that
who is that is that that's same risk
risk or me Wow I want now there is
nothing gay about bodybuilding am i
right nothing K its man judging other
men's
z I will say this we have opposing room
in Gold's Gym I pose him well I've been
there I'm sure I'm opposing in there
with my uncle he'd forced me to pose
there with my shirt on see I didn't I
didn't know this chapter
Oh your life so you spent your summers
in Venice and your uncle pax was a legit
body belt mr. universe he was mr.
universe timeless
oh Jesus and my aunt was mrs. universe
so so I grew up in with with those
spandex Shaab no packs bill packs peel
PA sex Pat yup and then B Beals a BB al
there it is
why don't we have a different last name
than your dad because he's not he's uh
was best way now yeah he he married into
the family oh wow that's my aunt though
that's Sophie Sean there she's got good
genetics too by the way mrs. universe
that's an absolutely amazing outfit
that's you helped do a picture yeah keep
calling he's like 70 there but he's nice
74 Dodd there Sonny for what 74 mr.
universe Wow packs people what happened
there was that uh he had a open-heart
surgery he had a heart attack and that's
when he got in crazy shape Wow
dr. film look at that well he's the best
made some cash too right uh-huh uh-huh
okay hey I mean they they basically
lived in [ __ ] Gold's Gym all these
Dan tastic those tights dude come on
yeah you have me do the poses it made no
sense because I built like Kermit the
Frog but you look up to him well yeah
he's my hero it's incredible when I
first moved to a fantasy that he had the
when I was a grown man when I moved to
Venice Ikey let me stay at his place
right cuz I can't afford to live
anywhere else so he let me stay at his
place and he goes my aunt was always
worried about it one let me stay there
he was like I'm Astaire don't tell
anyone I'm Alethea here's the
code again stuff he was all I ask is you
tell me the stories the girls you bring
over in [ __ ] that's a great uncle so I
first got a great uncle yeah I played
that cattle right there locks and
Olympic Trials he did yep
stud played football Cal did a track at
Cal epic trial laughs we boxing yeah
super stud okay shop stir yeah he was
the best man please Bart get that outfit
that's what I went there but when he
passed away and I knew they're gonna
flip the place I went there and got some
of his old stuff couldn't look better
than dude
yeah he's the best he's hilarious
PAC spheal
yeah Gold's is an interesting place you
see dudes to see a guy you're like big
good-looking guy but you know some
people just miss like you have your yeah
you have AG et on oh well yeah you got a
wife beater on tucked into your
sweatpants
when and we'd like Jazzercise songs oh
and you know end but you're also 35
what's going on what happened a lot of
broken dreams that finished there are
several you know if you see bigger
faster stronger you see those guys in
there and their vans in there there's
some don't get me wrong there's some
great people there some fantastic people
horse it's just it's never it's it's
very strange
I actually love it this is where
everything but it's just I actually it's
the guys are the biggest guys in the
world and they're doing dumbbells that
are 200 in each hand and then the girls
have these blah asses the shredded they
won't didn't put like insane shape okay
Franco Columbu dr. Franco Columbu got
his ph.d very close to Arnold he
recently passed away right yes he did he
was so stupid strong Arnold was not a
small man take a look at the tits on him
no dude take a look at the tits on him
and nervous Franco hang him by his feet
Franco was doing that old-school
functional fitness way back when dude
can you imagine being Franco and Arnold
in the [ __ ] 60s and 70s in Venice
Beach in Gold's Gym looking like him
famous Arnold was enemy girls he [ __ ]
you ever stopped don't look at him look
at that chick on the left
I love one night everybody loved oh say
our bodybuilders not strong watch kind
of weight they put on on there I got my
friend was saying that is it they're not
strong I was like that guy specially 500
pounds you don't know who would say
they're not strong oh the girl's body
when they don't get so [ __ ] up that's
a cool look right dad dumped a pump day
it dumped a that's a great [ __ ] look
right there it's tough man yeah that's
what you see a lot of though yeah so
some some people that just they've
they're just missing in some way so or
they're not what I want to do you know
that's all they want to do sure which I
can appreciate yeah I wish I could agree
cuz it's not all I want to do it's the
best mustache I've ever seen look great
hair it's very dark you gotta love that
guy that's a real mustache
Arnold ter fantastic Arnold was there
was a guy out there who's made for
bodybuilding it was Arnold yeah he's
made for Hollywood yeah made it cool
come on man look at that you kidding me
that doesn't make anyone do steroid it
does like I think he looks good he's one
of those few guys as a bodybuilder no
bodybuilding Rago
but but that was when Bobby Brown they
do whatever the all the deck in the
world and his genetics but yeah now it's
a bit now it's not fun now it's like now
there's so much [ __ ] or a pharmacy ya
know it's not like Arlo's gonna live to
an older age ease this new age like
Ronnie Coleman you have to have a
complete hip [ __ ] replacement like
all the HGH and these designer steroids
now if this guy's are [ __ ] it their
heads are this big now no one gives a
[ __ ] about mr. Limpy anymore it's the
game has changed man it's a bummer yep
did they just you know people don't know
when to stop
gotta get mom's bigger dude I gotta
start taking my bodybuilding more
seriously I started talking to Rogen on
Rogen about the trt the number of people
that hit me up with advice like hey
listen man I'm going to a doctor I'm not
you like you to do yes I dude look at me
do the money not meanwhile do you know
how I'm see what I'm doing it now I
[ __ ] my neck up today again well I
keep exacerbating it I gotta figure out
what's wrong I don't feel good right now
yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]